it's a good day foster haggis
and her son they've just received their
share of relief food brought in by the
united nations world food program
it's the first delivery of aid they've
received in months
as their and our family are among
millions of ethiopians displaced by the
conflict integra
region the family is sheltering an
abundant construction
site a few kilometers from their village
at the spot where their homeowners stood
as they and our family pick up the
pieces
there were about 20 armed men they
gathered around my house and thrashed
all my crops
i constantly have nightmares about how
brutal they were burning everything in
their way
they kept getting closer burning all of
the harvested crops and straw
they burned my home and everything i had
for the past six months the united
nations and aid agencies have repeatedly
called for full humanitarian access
to the tigray region in the face of
growing fears of a protracted conflict
with devastating effects on civilians so
this is a region that even prior to the
conflict has been
affected by shocks in recent years we
have the desert locusts this past year
hail storms
some pockets of the region that are
already chronically affected by drought
it means that this is an area that's
already a bit on the edge
in a new report a high-level un-led
committee estimated that about 350 000
people in the tigray region
are facing farming conditions
the war is now in its seventh month and
has hampered
access to essential services food water
and livelihoods
in large parts of the grey region
putting the lives of millions at risk
u.n staff integra continued to report
blocked movements of aid
as well as the interrogation assault
and even detention of humanitarian
workers at military checkpoints
the ethiopian government denies
responsibility
there are so many misinformations and
disinformations
going on not because of concern about
the ethereums but
because of the vested interest by others
who would like to present this situation
as
helpless situations there are forces who
like to show the government's effort as
they want to discredit it they want to
tell the rest of the world that the
government is doing nothing
the war in the tigray region of ethiopia
has displaced more than
2 million people and destroyed the
economy of the region
along with businesses crops and firms
thousands of civilians have also been
killed or wounded
aid agencies say now is the time to stop
thousands of others
from stabbing to death muhammad
al-jazeera
are the sovereign european